parce que l'eurovision unis est bonne ce
soir plus que jamais l'ukraine est dans
notre coeur bienvenue à la sélection
française 2022
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a la chance de pouvoir continuer à
nous amuser sur ce plateau donc à se
changer les idées on va essayer de le
faire en ayant quand même une pensée
évidemment pour les ukrainiens et je
voudrais d'ailleurs salué regarder cette
initiative pouvait certainement vu
passer sur les réseaux sociaux à défaut
de pouvoir lui remettre le prix nobel de
la paix ça c'est impossible certains ont
proposé la candidature de vladimir
poutine au prix nobel de médecine pour
avoir fait disparaître le covenant 19
dans le monde entier en 48 heures que
vous êtes le premier déploiement de la
force de réaction rapide de l'otan
depuis qu'elle existe
en tout cas sur le plan au niveau
terrestre je pense que bien sûr votre
action va rassurer les populations
locales mais nous ne sommes pas une
organisation humanitaire vous ne partez
pas distribuer des couvertures et de la
nourriture aux réfugiés
nous nous partons notre mission votre
vocation c'est distribuer du plomb à
ceux qui seraient les ennemis de la
france pour être honnête je suis pas
sûre qu'on y gagne à remplacer les
masques par des casques et même si vous
me donner un peu de temps je ne vais pas
tarder là à crier rendez-nous olivier
vers ans n'ont au mieux avant n'auront
pas vous oui presque tuent presque
incapable de le faire l'atelier de
fabrication des cocktails molotov est
situé dans cette arrière-cour cette
émission
vous connaissez le dosage
les épaules c'est la première fois que
vous faites ça oui c'est la première
fois pour nous tous
vous connaissez la recette sur internet
j'ai vu des publications qui expliquait
comment faire c'est devenu le coquen le
plus populaire en ukraine aujourd'hui
face aux conflits d'autres stars se sont
mobilisées ou tout du moins ont souhaité
témoigner sean penn était sur place aux
premiers jours de la guerre pour un
documentaire jared leto à lui partagé
une photo avec ses fans sur place il y a
quelques années l'acteur et ancien
gouverneur de californie arnold
schwarzenegger a écrit sur instagram ces
mots je partage votre douleur et votre
espoir de paix vous m'inspirez avec
votre courage et votre humanité face à
ce cauchemar que dieu vous bénisse et on
a même des bouteilles de vin français
lucide lucien vu comment tu prononces ça
c'est un cadeau des français pour les
tanks russes
merci l'europe
n'ont pas vous rayer là mais est ce que
c'est vraiment le moment de plaisanter
non justement actuellement vient ni
drôle c'est vrai que bon il faut quand
même aussi comment dire faire tenir un
peu les gens il faut leur proposer
au-delà du cinéma du théâtre continue à
vivre quoi moi j'ai l'impression
non les artistes et les artistes doivent
continuer malgré toi puis pro bowl et
peut-être dire quelque chose sur ce
sujet philippe envoyons d'orbey excusez
moi
nous émouvoir je sais pas je la
transmission la mignonneries elle a
tourné mes enfants l'identification
enfin la ménopause
[Rires]
là
ce joyeux lurons et depuis 20 ans à la
tête de l'institut français de yoga du
rire
toute l'année il organise des formations
pour les particuliers ou les salariés en
entreprise
ça fait du bien
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire est très
politisée oui je très politisée mais
c'est en fait j'étais en train de penser
est ce qu'on doit faire des émissions de
divertissement en pleine guerre
c'est sûr qu'on s'est posée
je n'avais pas de doute sur le fait
qu'on se pose tous mais je me dis mais
peut-être que faudrait arrêter
l'émission et descendra rue et dire on
arrête quand vous riez vous activer la
partie de votre cerveau qui gère les
émotions positives quand vous riez votre
créativité améliorer votre discernement
et améliorer votre qualité de décisions
prises à temps d'amaury est améliorée
super
c'est un peu du livre
l'autre jour un client est venu boire
avec un impact pas plus gros qu'une
pièce de deux euros seront pas prises
et je lui dit qu'est ce que tu veux que
ça me fasse moi ce que je veux savoir
c'est à acheter le dvd des [ __ ] elle
mais qui me répond ah bah non et bah du
coup je vais fait un deuxième impact
mais dans sa tronche et celui-là il est
beaucoup plus complexe 2 euros c'est
mende chef d'edc la junte en plâtre puis
hier soir valérie pécresse s'est
radicalisé en syrie pal pays 1
l'assistant vocal siri
elle parle officiellement de la même
façon dit série quel temps fait-il le
temps est venu de réparer la france
bleu
10 séries que doit faire emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron doit rendre des comptes
est ce que votre mère est une femme
politique oui ma mère est une femme
politique à ces noms
à toulouse donc si on dit votre nom là
tout le monde le connaît la france
entière
politique un peu politique ses deux fils
d'anne hidalgo pourquoi politique
série comment sont les faits les faits
sont implacables bon allez une dernière
après j'arrête j'ai peur de la casse et
10 séries que faudrait-il faire
pour cela il faudrait du courage c'est
très très peur mais le muguet des
cochons d'inde sont des cochons avec la
bande à porter
[Musique]
je ne peux pas non mais c'est pas
possible par des cauchemars mettre à
pleurer je peux partager c'est
complètement famille qui voyant bien
droit dans les yeux ça mais le
spoiler dur bras dans les yeux alors est
ce que vous êtes le fils d'anne hidalgo
oui je suis
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous dites encore je t'aime à
vos parents moi pas trop il faudrait
leur dire un jour mais je pense que ça
fait partie des blocages ou est ce qu'on
peut appeler votre mère et lui dire je
t'aime
allez
ça va c'était juste pour te dire que je
t'aimais
non non ce n'est pas du nord
une prise de parole retransmise en
direct sur bfm bfm quelqu'un avait
oublié qu'à la télé on porte des micros
résultat on entend ce qu'on dit dans les
micros
je vous remercie
la pitié voilà pour ces déclarations de
valérie pécresse pour moi pis aller ma
femme tente là les parcelles
foutu goût ma femme est parfait elle
s'appelle comment votre femme sont
abattues ce moment simone en voiture
simone
persimmon et moi qui conduis c'était un
siècle
[Rires]